[Musique]
il vit son rêve et le partage sans
retenue avec ses nombreux fans mais
qu'elle pouvait encore des projets plein
la tête il nous attend ici à saint louis
où il continue à écrire les pages de son
histoire
j'ai donné tout ce qu'ils attendent
comme fait tout pour un trait mais je
leur code d'un la rai tre printemps dont
j'oublie je te tue devient ce qui te
fait fi
est-ce pas tes rêves en prison tu sauras
ce qui te fait rire quand tu écouteras
la voix au front
[Musique]
oui
merci michael pouvant de nous accueillir
pour nous parler de ta passion la
musique le chant comment ça t'es venue
cette passion là je sais pas si je peux
dire que c'est inné mais en tout cas
j'aime la musique j'aime chanter c'est
quelque chose qui me passionne depuis
vraiment tout petit et que j'ai
développé au fil du temps qu'est ce qui
t'a amené à te dire je veux devenir
chanteur ça a toujours été là ça a
toujours été un viscérale cette envie de
chanter de partager sa participer à
l'émission the voice alors à l'époque
j'étais encore étudiant c'était pas
évident parce qu'on faisait beaucoup
d'allers-retours j'avais déjà passé les
auditions à l'aveuglent je rentre à la
réunion j'étais étudiant donc ça me
faisait vraiment bizarre et jetés en
mode c'est pas ma place et il ya quelque
chose d'autre qui m'appelle en fait ça
va être compliqué ça va être difficile
mais c'est vraiment de participer à
cette émission là qui m'a fait réaliser
que j'avais envie d'autre chose
laisse-moi coûte
ap
l'auteur
sa voix
du mot
alors il ya eu notamment succès de
l'album éternel son deuxième album qui
est allé au delà de la réunion est ce
que tu t'y attendais non pas du tout
c'est
c'était assez inespéré surprenant
mais en même temps
même temps c'est vrai qu'on peut pas se
mentir c'est ça fait partie du rêve et
c'est quelque chose qui au fond de soi
donc quand ça arrive et que ça dépasse
les frontières locales mais c'est énorme
et franchement j'ai énormément de
gratitude tous les matins je suis là
dire merci la vie pour tout ce que j'ai
la chance de vivre quand on vois tu as
ta bonne humeur on se demande c'est quoi
ton moteur qu'est ce qui te fait avancer
tous les jours je suis un grand rêveur
donc
j'essaye de ne pas me donner de limites
et ça fait que le matin je sais que
quand je me réveille
j'ai un but je le connais mon pourquoi
je sais pourquoi je me réveille je suis
quelqu'un d'ambitieux aussi donc j'ai la
chance aussi d'avoir une super équipe
qui me suivent là dedans dans mes
délires dans mes envies j'ai trop forcé
de chemin
c'était limite on a le feu sacré d'amour
thumeries de nous
tempez on sera déjà noir très décevant
[Musique]
connaît pas de fin et des étoiles alors
je pense que le public m'en voudrais si
je te demandais pas un message pour
toutes les fans merci c'est le premier
mot qui me vient en lettres capitales
tu touches et à chaque fois certaines
personnes me disent des fois oui on doit
te dire ça à tous les jours et ceram et
non à chaque compliments aux messages
positifs qu'on me donne je viens dit
mais ça me va me va droit au coeur en
fait je prends et
je me nourris de ça donc merci au public
insu voilà merci à toi michael prue 20
pour ce moment d'augmenter de partage
avec vous merci c'est green